طموح الهلال في كاس العالم للانديه هذا
موضوعنا اليوم بحلقه جديده من برنامجكم
بعد الصافره معي انا عبيده نفاع
[موسيقى]
نادي الهلال في كاس العالم الماضي الذي
اقيم في ابوظبي واجه مين وواجه تشيلسي
بنصف النهائي وخسر بنتيجه 1-0 بوحده من
افضل مباريات الانديه العربيه ضد الانديه
الكبرى في العالم حتى ذلك الحين انه كان
واحد من افضل المستويات التي قدمتها الفرق
العربيه انديه ومنتخبات امام الفرق
والمنتخبات الكبيره طبعا هذا الكلام كان
قبل فوز السعوديه على الارجنتين وفوز تونس
على فرنسا ووصول المغرب لنصف نهائي كاس
العالم الماضي في قطر والكل كان في ذلك
الوقت متفائل باداء الهلال وكنا شايفين
الاعلام الانجليزي بالملعب يعني نوعا ما
متوتر خلال مباراه لانه كان نجم المباراه
من جانب نادي تشيلسي هو
وكان الهلال بشكل خطوره من كل النواحي عن
طريق محمد كنو عن طريق ماريجا عن طريق
سالم الدوسري وكانت الامور يعني ممتازه
جدا بالنسبه للفريق الهلالي اللي كان قادر
يكون نت قوي جدا لتشيلسي في ذلك الحين لما
تكون قادر انك تواجه تشيلسي وتقدم هذا
المستويات الكبيره لما منتخبك يفوز على
الارجنتين بكاس العالم لما يكون عندك قوام
هذا المنتخب نعم سلمان الفرج مصاب نعم
ياسر الشهراني مصاب نعم كل هذا الكلام
ولكن على ارض الواقع محمد العويس موجود صح
حارس احتياطي ولكن ايضا عبد الله المعيوف
حارس جيد عندك سالم الدوسري موجود علي
البلاي موجود محمد كانه موجود هؤلاء هم
قوام المنتخب السعودي كانوا بكاس العالم
افضل لاعبي المنتخب السعودي بكاس العالم
موجودين مع الهلال اليوم لذلك ما عندك عذر
انك ما تطمح لللقب ما تطمح لانك تجيب
اللقب في ناس راح تعترض وتقول لا يا عمي
هذا كلام غير منطقي وعندك عندك ريال مدريد
وعندك فلامنجو البرازيلي وعندك الاهلي
المصري وما الى ذلك مباراه الاهلي دائما
مباراه ديربي مع الهلال وقد يفوز الاهلي
في مباريات الهلال في مباريات اخرى مش
مختلفين ولكن على ارض الواقع تعال نحكي عن
مباراه ريال مدريد هل ريال مدريد عم بيعيش
افضل بالوقت الراهن ابدا ريال مدريد ليس
في افضل احواله خطوره ريال مدريد ومفاتيح
اللعب الرئيسيه ان ريال مدريد غير موجوده
هذا الموسم بنزيما مش بنزيما موسم الماضي
مودريتش مش مودريتش
لدرجه نيك مش عم يلعبوا بشكل اساسي هذا
الموسم عم يعتمد عليهم
كاحتياطيوس
عند الريال اضف الى ذلك انه فينيسيوس
جونيور ايضا مش فينيسيوس الموسم الماضي
كورتوا مش كورتوا الموسم الماضي وبالتالي
ريال مدريد ليس ذلك الفريق الذي كان عليه
في موسم اللي جاب في دوري الابطال واللي
جاب فيه الدوري ريال مدريد الان يعيش في
مرحله شك مرحله فراغ مرحله تاخر بالدوري
امام برشلونه بفارق ثمان نقاط قد يصل الى
خمس نقاط لهم اذا فاز ريال مدريد ولكن
باخر النهار ريال مدريد مش ريال مدريد
اللي كان سابقا
اوروبا وسياتون ايضا المنتخب السعودي بين
قدرات لعيبته بكاس العالم الماضي بقطر
وخرج نعم من الدور الاول ولكن كان ممكن
انه يصل ويروح بعيد لو قدم مباراه جيده
امام بولندا لذلك ما عندك اي عذر انك ما
تطمح لتحقيق اللقب العالمي هذا بالنهايه
شخصي اراكم بالتاكيد هي المهمه وخلانا
نشوف وين راح نروح الهلال بكاس العالم
للانديه هذا كان كل شيء بحلقه لون بعض
الصافي لحتى نلتقي الاسبوع المقبل بكونوا
بالف خير
[تصفيق]